rather most salah as you can see on the
screen um shared something with his wife
his wife is a hijabi sister
and obviously she's covering herself
with a hoodie but it's more christmasy
and jackie i celebrate christmas i used
to wrap gifts presents christmas
turkey dinner a lot of you guys that
don't understand the severity and the
consequences
to you it's like brother andy what's the
hulk come on for god's sake
from a juvenile when my clothes had
holes in them
and my afro is picky to the night east
moschino and versace no laces in our
cheese new millennium assalamu alaikum
what happened today
to you brothers and sisters and dear
friends welcome back inshallah so um
i've been getting a lot of uh messages
uh regarding brother uh masala
and the pictures that he shared i think
he did he shared
one last year as well and again today
and this year as well
um so now we want to come at this from a
different angle yeah i
i was i was very double-minded should i
do this video or not but i thought
generally let's just
firstly uh talk about the rights of
another believer number one number two
let's just talk about
in general about christmas yeah now many
videos have been done over and over
again and this is something where
a lot of people think you know what
what's like what's the big deal let's
just get into inshallah yeah so rather
most salah as you can see on the screen
um shared something with his wife his
wife is a hijabi sister
and obviously she's covering herself
with a hoodie but it's more christmassy
and her daughter's there now what we're
going to do is we're going to be talking
about in general firstly
for us to assume the best in a muslim
it's very important when these things
come up a lot of people jump on the
bandwagon and be like oh yeah can i
attack him
you know he's a cafe and he's like this
he's like that and send hate that's not
the right attitude because at the end of
the day brother sisters
do i believe that mausa knowing what
it symbolizes and what he's doing do you
think he really does it on purpose does
he think to himself you know what
i know let me use this symbol that is uh
rooted in the pagan traditions or
christmas
uh as well which believe is paganism as
well uh they believe believing that this
is jesus's birth and they believe jesus
to be the son of god or god incarnated
we need to make something clear sending
hate is not going to solve anything but
it's good to
educate you maybe when you're given the
seer do it in a nice and good manner
uh it's very important for us to do that
so when you're addressing him just say
bravo most salah
maybe give him some information maybe he
doesn't know you know there's actually
biblical verses yeah in the book of
jeremiah it's it's it actually talks
about christmas who's very very
profound you know even some christians
deem it to be some kind of pagan ritual
so if you go to the book of jeremiah
just jeremiah so we can just understand
uh jeremiah 10 verse 1 to 5 it says
hear you the word which the lord
speaketh unto you a house of israel
though saith the lord learn the way of
the heathen and be not dismayed at the
sign of heaven the heathen is the
disbeliever
for the heathen are dismayed at them for
the customs of the people are vain for
one cut of a tree
out of the forest the work of the hands
of the workman with the axe
they deck it with silver and with gold
they fasten it with nails and with
hammers then
that it move not they are upright as the
palm tree but speak not they must need
to needs to be born they must need to be
born
because they cannot go be not afraid of
them for they cannot do evil neither
also
is it in them to do good this is very
interesting because it's
very at the end of this verse it's like
they saw maybe the tree as some kind of
a
um something that brings luck because
the in the book of jeremiah it clearly
says
for they cannot do evil neither also is
it that they can do good so what does
allah tell us in the quran about pagans
they can neither bring you good or bad
they can neither harm you or bring you
good
you know they're just something that's
inanimate objects so even the bible is
referring to them and some christians
didn't even acknowledge that that it
comes from paganism
so but now let's understand and let's
advise people in general yeah so
salah you might be watching this if
you're watching this genuinely brother i
don't believe you
did this on purpose like you think that
but it's very profound because allah
says in surah maryam verse
verse 19. allah says
by which the heavens are about to burst
the earth split apart
and the mountains to crumble with pieces
in protest of attributing children of uh
to the most
compassionate brothers and sisters what
let's understand something here
now a lot of you guys so for example i
did a video on um tik tok
where i went to a arab uh a muslim shop
from a mistake and it was a christmas
tree father christmas was there yet
when you come to arab muslim shop and
you see my man rolling here
i would be there now what we need to
understand is that these things
gradually
evolve now i as a non-muslim back in
jail i
celebrate christmas i used to wrap gifts
presents christmas
turkey dinner etc you know i used to eat
pork like you know i used to celebrate
christmas
with a uh half christian half
muslim family yeah yeah
i won't get too much details but the
thing is i used to celebrate christmas
with them every single year we used to
get gifts
and everything now the thing is as i
started studying the religion then i
understood
um the severity of that and now a lot of
you guys that don't understand the
severity and the consequences to you
it's like brother ali what's the hell
come on for god's sake
brothers and sisters if we understood
what [ __ ] is
and most of the time this happens
because we are ignorant to it now i
don't want you guys to see this as some
kind of
me having a go at you look i was
ignorant at one point there's not
there's there's nothing wrong with not
knowing in the context of
like you should educate yourself yeah
okay i'm not going to go at you but it's
important for you to learn
allah singing the mountains in the quran
the heavens are about to burst the
mountains the earth is about to split
apart
the mountains are about to crumble the
statement that they utter that isla
islam
and if i'm not mistaken one of the
brothers told us that the star that they
have on the tree that they put
is a star of bethlehem and this is where
they
uh followed that star to find jesus
which they deem to be the son of god
or um part of the trinity yeah and
to those non-muslims that are watching
this and trying to understand where
we're coming from
look you have every right to celebrate
christmas this is your country you can
celebrate it all day
all night it doesn't bother us celebrate
as much as you like but what we're
trying to do and even in islamic land
even if it was run by the islamic
rulership christians can celebrate and
they can have their own churches they
have the rights to celebrate
we're not here to say you're not allowed
to celebrate you offended me no
you can do that we believe it to be
wrong but what is more confusing and i
feel sorry for reverse
is because those who celebrate christmas
when they see muslims doing it they're
going to be saying to their reverse
family members who say i can't celebrate
hold on a second there's muslims like
musa he's a muslim
he's he's celebrating it you put rivas
in a situation where the family's
thinking are you trying to be awkward
you know but this is why it's very sad
so let's understand
that you guys can celebrate but to us
the severity is so big
just imagine for example there was a
symbol
there was a specific tree or whatever it
may be there was some kind of
connections
to let's suppose a person in your family
die a member of your family died
with someone uh cutting them into pieces
and and that from that moment onwards we
were celebrating using a specific knife
and we used to hang the knife right on
top of the tree
or something along those lines now
sheikh associating partners to god is
one million
trillion billion times worse than that
now you might not fathom and understand
that
but that does not mean that what's
happening is not it's not wrong
just because you can't grasp something
because of cultural barriers or
differences
or religious whatever it may be doesn't
mean it's not wrong but for muslims you
guys should know better
associate partners allah is the one who
feeds you otherwise they want to close
you
allah has given you everything that you
have all the blessings that you have
all the blessings so much so there is a
hadith of the prophet peace be upon him
who said a man will come under their
judgment the righteous man
and he will say allah will say to him
enter my paradise he will say allah i
want to enter with my good deeds
allah say okay and he'll bring the mizan
the weighing of the deeds that day
and allah will say okay let's get all
your good deeds we'll put in one side
and let's get your eye the blessing of
your eye and put it on the other
the i will outweigh all the good things
this man did for a hundred years
that he did and the allah what would
allah say allah will say you have to go
hell fire
now first it was paradise now the man
will say oh allah
please i will end up enter me into
paradise with your mercy not with your
justice because if it's based on your
justice i am indebted to you
the moment i'm born to whatever i do i
can never pay you
back so the man allah says okay enter my
paradise but what is the point here the
point here is
firstly we enter paradise by the mercy
of allah not by our good deeds this is
this doesn't mean you don't do your good
things you do your good deeds because of
who allah
is but the point is this brothers and
sisters
for us to understand the severity while
life brothers and sisters how ungrateful
it is
imagine if you did something that hurt
your mom's feelings imagine you did
something that your mom did not like
imagine if your mum said you know what
i've looked after you all this
time or your dad said i've done this way
i've worked hard to bring you up and i
don't want you to have this in the house
you would say you know what at least out
of appreciation and loved him and
gratitude
my dad doesn't like it let me not do it
you know his happiness
brothers and sisters what about allah
what about the one who created the
heavens and the earth
brothers and sisters what about him
indeed in the creation of the heavens
and earth and in the alternation of the
night and day
there are signs for those who believe or
who have wisdom who are you thinking
brothers and sisters you look around you
you see everything you see the stars and
everything
and allah has created me and you he's
given us everything
while i when i say this i'm getting
emotional why because france says what
lies the pinnacle of
gratitude it's the pinnacle you might
think to yourself oh how dramatic
brother ali it's the pinnacle of
ingratitude
he gives you everything and something
that's connecting to [ __ ]
something that is you might say okay
it's a festival now it's the people
don't use it
irrelevant because it's connected to
their wall
he don't do it anything that is
connected to a some kind of indirect way
of gratitude to my mom and dad i would
not do it
let's tell them the one who's created
heavens and the earth little one the one
who provides for me he looks after me
let alone the one and
and i'm grateful for the sin subhanallah
and on top of that we want to go and uh
treat and i'm not having a god mostly me
he's maybe doing it because he doesn't
know and for you guys who are doing it
you might not know for once put allah
first in your life and i want to end on
this note
brothers and sisters when it comes to
these issues you need to understand the
people who commit shirk
the people the pagan arabs who who
commit the ship they didn't wake up one
day and say hey i know let's start
worship
yeah and let's let's worship them they
didn't do that
these people these individuals paid in
these um
statues that they had idols these were
righteous individuals who used to feed
pilgrims i don't know which one it was
i can't remember they used to feed
pilgrims when they died
shaitan came that came to them and said
look why don't you do build some kind of
like a
in their memory yeah and what happened
the future generation
and the next generation turned that into
[ __ ] slowly
do you think jesus when he came people
took him as god no
no the council of masai in 325
and a generation after generation did
what deified them further and deified
them further and deified them further
first he was not a part of god then he
became a part of god you know and and
you saw how it evolved
now most allah his daughter may allah
bless her and make her a righteous child
a a
a righteous daughter and all of our
children as well
if she sees your father doing this yeah
like i said and all of us if you see
your father doing this and
the children will have to look up to
them do you not think she's gonna end up
carrying
uh um celebrating christmas do you think
the children is going to come to a point
where they're gonna say okay let's look
into this you know maybe
end up becoming christians or whatever
it may be brothers and sisters this is
where things
lay down you might be good and this is
the reason why i have this book here you
see this book here
the devil's deception read it read it
this is how the devil shaytan comes to
us
he doesn't come to us directly and said
hey man you know you know why don't you
start coming
no shaytan has stages he's gonna get you
so don't be deceived by
you take precautions because if please
will come and say oh what's the harm
of course it's just a christmas tree
don't put your guards down
you have one life and you either pass it
or you fail it
please brothers and sisters and i'm
asking you guys please be gentle with
people do not be harsh and
aggressive i hope this video in any more
inshallah i hope you guys have benefited
do give me a comment section uh in the
uh section below inshallah
uh and let me know how you feel and hope
you guys benefited me i also happen to
have
brotherhood and all of us inshallah and
let's be gentle towards the believers
they have rights over us this will be
harsh towards them
and may allah protect us from shirk the
minute to the major may allah protect us
inshallah and make us amongst those who
are grateful to our lord
and serve this religion until next time
assalamu alaikum warahmatullahi